after more than a year of covet
restrictions
las vegas obviously trying to get closer
to whatever
normal is so this is the final week of
state control
before regulations get handed over to
the counties
our hector mahia live near the strip
taking a look at how things are going to
change what's it all about hector
hey there nate good morning to you and
it's coming up soon this saturday may
1st is when the county takes over
control of the rules and these are the
two big changes you'll see
building capacity is going to increase
from the current fifty percent up to
eighty percent
as far as social distancing goes that's
going down
from six feet down to three feet also
restaurants will be able to have 12
people
at a table instead of six buffets and
food sampling can resume as well
starting saturday
soaking nightclubs day clubs and adult
entertainment
dance floors however are still
prohibited until the county's first dose
vaccination rate
reaches 60 percent as of last week we
were just pretty
pretty short of the 50 percent
benchmarks are really close
so that's another incentive to get the
shot and if we can hit 60
with at least one dose all social
distancing
and capacity limits will go away here in
clark county and as far as casinos go
here we have the win
and encore right behind us and also
resorts world
just off to that side well capacity
inside those places will also increase
starting saturday well that's not open
yet but at the places that are open
that capacity increasing up to 80
percent as well starting this saturday
so a lot of changes nate
headed our way in just a matter of days